[Musique]
ces visages vous sont peut-être
familiers pour les reconnaître il faut
se plonger 20 ans en arrière Louis
cordiss et Josh Erdman ont incarné les
deux acolytes de Drago Malefoy dans
Harry Potter les deux acteurs sont venus
rendre visite à leur fans à l'occasion
du geek-up festival aux Clayes-sous-Bois
Harry Potter est de nombreuses
franchises Star Wars le Seigneur des
Anneaux ça représente tellement
important de personnes différentes
donc c'est bien de rencontrer les fans
et de leur rendre l'appareil parce que
vous savez Harry Potter nous a tellement
donné avec lui
c'est bien de venir ici dans des
endroits charmants comme ça et de leur
rose qui nous donne
des personnes normales et que les rêves
peuvent être réalisés parce que ça peut
être un de leurs rêves de faire partie
de quelque chose comme ça et nous sommes
la preuve que cela peut arriver
illustrateur plusieurs dessinateur ou
encore artisans de l'autre côté du parc
les fans de pop culture on peut
également découvrir de nombreuses stands
et animations sur leur univers favoris
je suis sculptriste sur argile polymère
donc je fais essentiellement de la
décoration d'intérieur et je m'inspire
beaucoup de tout ce qui va être univers
fantaisie fantastique pour découvrir les
jeux de société notamment ceux et
figurines qui sont pas très connus
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui permet
beaucoup plus de d'interaction entre
joueurs qui favorise la coopération et
qui fait aussi beaucoup d'immersion par
rapport à des scénarios plus poussés
qu'un jeu de société normal à
l'allemande et même se découvrir Jedi en
s'initiant au sabre laser mon combat
avec un sabre laser qui est de cette
forme là donc on a une lame en
polycarbonate
ce qu'on appelle un émetteur qui est
dans le promo donc les metteur il est là
on tient en général le sabre avec sa
main dominante au niveau de l'émetteur
et le une deuxième main en bas en bas de
du pommeau on a un petit bouton en
général pour l'allumer concours de
cosplay rencontre entre passionnés ou
simple curiosité chacun a pu y trouver
son compte aujourd'hui si la curiosité
j'ai vu la fiche hier en arrivant au
niveau de la gare donc je me suis dit
bah tiens voilà c'est l'occasion j'avais
envie il est beau et c'est plutôt sympa
je suis venu sur Internet vite fait un
petit événement comme ça je me suis dit
pourquoi pas y aller on va par exemple
je suis plus dans les mangas la chaîne
animée ou même dans les jeux vidéo du
style Dragon Ball etc moi
[Musique]
j'aime le juge pas c'est franchement
j'adore et j'aime beaucoup aussi les
concours les concours d'aspects j'aime
beaucoup passer sur scène et tout ça
voir le public heureux toute l'équipe en
fait on a vu de près ou de loin des
conventions et on a vu ce qu'on aimait
on a vu ce qu'on aimait pas et on s'est
dit on veut faire quelque chose de de
local de familial quelque chose qui qui
soit justement pas à Paris qui soit
accessible aussi à tout le monde une
prochaine édition et d'ores et déjà
prévu pour l'année prochaine sur le
thème du sport un clin d'oeil aux Jeux
Olympiques 2024 qui se dérouleront
notamment à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines